[Music]
this is
um
good morning everybody thank you for
being here uh
it's nice that the first event we throw
at the stadium is is with this group of
people and
we uh we're honored to have you here and
thank you that uh we're starting early
uh this will probably be the first time
an event here starts early so thanks for
everyone for coming
um truly an honor and humbling to be
here
uh on on 911
we just want to thank you for everything
you do to keep our community safe
everything you do to keep our families
and loved ones safe it's important you
don't hear it enough especially now
so we just wanted to tell you we
appreciate it and thank you very much
for everything that you do uh
thank everyone else for for being here
obviously the circumstances surrounding
the start of the season
are not ideal but we are still very
excited and proud
of allegion stadium it's it's beautiful
it's better looking than the renderings
and a lot of people in this community
were a big part
of making it happen and none more so
than who i'm going to introduce right
now
michael was involved both in his
previous position and in his current
position
in making sure this stadium got built
got built safely got built on time
and will be a treasure for this
community for decades to come
so thank you michael we appreciate it uh
clark county commissioner michael naft
good morning thank you so much mark when
i had initially called
uh mark bedan to ask him if we could
invite
the heroes i'm standing with today to
join us uh here on september 11th
uh i couldn't barely finish the sentence
before he agreed
i think that speaks so much to the
organization he's helped build to their
quality their character
and really to the community partner that
they are and that the las vegas raiders
will continue to be
here in southern nevada 19 years ago
today
our nation was changed forever many of
us can recall exactly where we were
when we learned that four airplanes had
been hijacked
and used to attack targets in the united
states
two of the planes were flown into the
twin towers of the world trade center in
new york city
a third plane hit the pentagon just
outside washington dc
and the fourth plane crashed into a
field in shanksville pennsylvania
2977 were killed
during the 9 11 terrorist attacks and
too many to count were injured and have
sustained injuries to this day
that one moment in history has impacted
the course of all of our lives
here in las vegas we felt the personal
impact of losing palo verde high school
teacher
barbara edwards we saw the challenges of
shutting down the national airspace
and an uncertain future
in the days that followed we learned of
the first responders who rushed into the
wreckage
as thousands ran out of ordinary
citizens who banded together to take
down flight 93
and save countless lives of neighbors
sheltering neighbors
and restaurateurs preparing food for
rescue workers
through all of this millions of
americans were inspired to action
including trooper jason baratsuk who is
with us today
trooper baratsuk was working for a small
airline in massachusetts
going about his daily routine when the
first plane struck
like many of us he was angry at first
but he turned that anger into service
he was inspired to join the united
states air force
and later the net nevada highway patrol
september 11th 2001 touched all of us in
different ways
some like trooper baritsuke and many
that i'm standing with today were called
into military service
others were drawn into the medical field
in hopes of being able to save a life in
need
others still take this day each year as
a day of service
to give back to our community and to
make the world a better place
while we all remember the events of 9 11
in our own way
i believe it is our responsibility to
take this day to recognize the heroes
among us
those that live in our neighborhoods and
routinely put their life
on the line that is why i asked each
of our first responding organizations
here in southern nevada
to nominate one individual to represent
the thousands of police officers
firefighters medics those
in our community who make up our
emergency services and i can tell you
i've never felt more safe in my life
than i am right now so i thank them
so much i'm honored to stand with them
and as i uh announce the names of the
organizations that they represent i'll
ask them to take a step forward and wave
and be acknowledged
amr las vegas
boulder city police department
ccsd police
city of las vegas department of public
service
clark county fire department
clark county pub park police
community ambulance
henderson fire department
henderson police department
las vegas fire and rescue
las vegas metropolitan police department
medic west the mesquite police
department
the nevada highway patrol
and university police services please
join me in thanking all of them and the
organizations they represent
their commitment to protecting our
community is paramount and
as you can see by this representation it
it takes a village and it takes so many
people coming together
to make our community safe to welcome
back
the 43 million plus visitors to our
community
and when we come to fill this stadium
behind me these are the people who are
going to keep it safe
so this is uh personal for a lot of us
it's personal for me and i'm just
honored to share this day
and acknowledge them as we should every
day
i always ask everyone in our community
if you see a first responder out there
take a moment thank them for what they
do they need it and they need to know
that they have our bet that we have
their back
at this time i'd like to introduce
captain kenneth young
and the honor guard for the national
anthem and the raising of our flag in
honor of all those we've lost on
september 11
2001 and the military conflicts that
followed
it is in the tradition of our country
that we raise the flag
at this time thank you very much
beautiful
oh
oh say can you
see by the dawn's early light
was so roundly we
hailed at the twilight's
last gleaming
whose broad stripes and bright stars
through the perilous
fight all the ramparts we
watched were so gallantly
streaming
and the rockets red glare
the bombs bursting in
air gave proof
through the night that our flag was
still
there oh
say does that star-spangled
banner yet away
[Music]
oh the land of the free
[Music]
and the home
of the race
thank you so much with more than 75
million americans born
since september 11 2001 it is vital that
we never forget but also that we
continue to educate our students on the
events that took place
and the heroes that were born that day
thank you for being here and help
telling the story of the brave
individuals who stand behind me and i
stand with
now i'm so grateful to the las vegas
raiders who've invited each of our
special honored guests today to take
part in a tour of the stadium and
see this beautiful facility thank you
very much and please have a good day
[Music]
beautiful job
what up man
keeping you busy
good
sorry okay
do you need me to hold it for you i just
wanted to double check
okay
[Music]
how's it going
[Music]
let's try this
you guys ready
it was nice that the first event was in
honor of the first responders police
fire ambulatory
all the people that keep our community
safe keep our families safe
so the fact that we were able to host
them this morning on 9 11
and give them a tour i think is pretty
special
yeah certainly i mean it was uh six
o'clock in the morning we're in
california
and you wake up to that shocking news um
and obviously the the terror and and and
the fear that that ripped the nation and
then
the power of everyone to come back and
come back strong but as i was sharing
with some of
the law enforcement officers important
to remember important to keep it
in people's memories it's been 19 years
today's new cycle is very very fleeting
and very fast
and as a country and as a world we can't
really forget what happened on that and
we need to honor
the folks that were the heroes and and
went in and risked their lives and lost
their lives to save others
this community has been uh amazing to us
and we've gotten to know them over the
last four and a half years uh saw the
response after october one see the
response on a daily basis
they've been involved in everything
related to the stadium construction and
and planning and be a big part of it for
an operations standpoint so
uh they're very important the raid
organization always have been and always
will be in the future
yeah so the group's getting a tour of
allegiance stadium right now so excited
to show them our new home
what does it mean the raiders
show the appreciation to
our first responders and to say hey
well the raiders have always had a very
uh positive working relationship with
law enforcement with the military
uh that's been in our past and it'll
continue here so the fact that we had
representatives from every single
department
i think shows that that continuity and
that community spirit and that
that partnership that we have with them
anyone else no
sorry one more time a couple weeks
monday night oh ten days opening day
uh well we have a game on sunday so like
they say you look at the opponent that's
in front of us so we're worried about
the panthers the team
gets on the plane in about five hours
and heads back east and
look uh look to go 1-0 thanks
all right good yeah you got it thanks
guys
okay
my name is captain fred haas
f-r-e-d-h-a-a-s
and you're with uh metro las vegas metro
perfect
what does this day be to you this day is
very important to me
on 9 11 in 2001 i was in the academy
here at metro
just starting my career and watching
this community in this nation grieve
was heartbreaking to be here today 19
years later to watch the birth of the
las vegas raiders to be a part of this
as they come online and they come to
play the games here and
be a part of our community is just
incredibly special
just to see the raiders just step up i
mean this is huge
and now you guys get to go on a tour of
the stadium
that's correct so we're getting a tour
of the las vegas stadium today as being
recognized as a first responder in las
vegas
um it's hard to believe that this is
here we never thought sports would come
here and be a part of this is just
amazing
are you from las vegas i'm not you know
just seeing this seeing how the city
grows and to see how the raiders
has taken charge to be part of this
community
um what is your message to the city uh
to the city of las vegas
and how important it is for all of us to
come together on a day like this
it's important for us to come together
as a community with the raiders with the
knights
just as one another to love one another
to be a part of one each other and care
for one another
having the violence that goes on you
know we don't see it here as much but
it's important that we
don't do that here that we be a part of
a community and that's taking care of
each other
thank you thank you sir
good morning good morning
i did well in the weeks leading up to
this commemoration
uh i called mark bodaine of the raiders
and before i could even finish my
sentence and tell him what we wanted to
do here today
he wholeheartedly agreed and was willing
to offer the stadium as
the host facility for this incredible
day where we can not only commemorate
the lives of
all those we lost on the attacks in 9
11.
but also and i think equally important
that we honor
those heroes that are with us every
single day that get up every morning in
our local community here in southern
nevada
put on their uniform and get out there
and help keep this economy going keep us
safe for visitors to come
and when this stadium is filled
hopefully soon
they will be the key people to who help
keep it safe
i was in i was my freshman year of high
school at las vegas academy
i recall riding the bus on the way to
school and first finding out it was in
the early days i think of text messaging
and you first started getting all the
scattered reports and then throughout
the day every teacher handled it a
little differently
most put the tv set on and just allowed
us to sort of watch the news and absorb
it all
but no doubt being a part of that
generation impacted my life
it's part of what made me want to get
involved in public service
and it's certainly what added to the
respect that i have for
those in law enforcement and our first
responders
what is your message to the las vegas
i think it's important on days like this
but it's really important that every
single day we take the opportunity to
thank
firefighters medics police officers who
are willing to sacrifice
and put their life on the line and the
contributions that they and their
families make in order to keep us safe
keep our economy thriving and growing
thank you so much thank you all for
being here thank you
hey have a great day
is